ED HENRY HAS A FULL REPORT
TONIGHT AND THAT'S ALL
COMING UP IN OUR BREAKING
NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ WE START TONIGHT WITH A
STUNNING PIECE OF
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING FROM
PAUL SPERRY.
WE HAVE TOLD YOU THAT THE
TWO REPUBLICAN MEMOS ABOUT
SEVERE FISA ABUSES.
WE GAVE ALL THE DETAILS AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL SPIES ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WE TOLD YOU THIS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING OF WHAT IS COMING.
TONIGHT THERE IS A NEW
DEVELOPMENT IN THIS MASSIVE
SCANDAL.
ACCORDING TO OFFICERY, THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
IS NOW FOCUSING ON SEVERAL
KEY FORMER OBAMA
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS WHICH
INCLUDE JOHN BRENNAN AND
JAMES CLAPPER AND THEIR
CONNECTIONS TO THE STEELE
DOSSIER THAT WAS FILLED WITH
HILLARY CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR RUSSIAN LIES.
LET'S START WITH THE FORMER
CIA DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN.
ACCORDING TO PAUL OFFICERY'S
NEW REPORTING THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE IS
INVESTIGATING WHETHER OR NOT
BRENNAN COMMITTED PERJURY
WHEN TESTIFYING UNDER OATH
ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
AND HERE'S WHAT BRENNAN SAID
BACK IN MAY OF 2017.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
>> DIRECTOR BRENNAN, DO YOU
KNOW WHO COMMISSIONED THIS
STEELE DOSSIER?
>> I DON'T.
>> DO YOU KNOW IF THE BUREAU
EVER RELIED ON THE STEELE
DOSSIER AS ANY -- AS PART OF
ANY COURT FILINGS?
APPLICATIONS?
PETITIONS?
PLEADINGS?
>> I HAVE NO AWARENESS.
>> DID THE CIA RELY ON IT.
>> NO.
>> WHY NOT?
>> BECAUSE WE DIDN'T.
IT WASN'T PART OF THE CORPUS
OF INTELLIGENCE INFORMATION
THAT WE HAD.
IT WAS NOT IN ANY WAY USED
AS A BASIS FOR THE INTEL
COMMUNITY'S ASSESSMENT THAT
WAS DONE.
IT WAS NOT.
>> Sean: SO WE'RE TO BELIEVE
JOHN BRENNAN THE FORMER HEAD
OF THE CIA CLAIMING UNDER
OATH THAT HE HAD NO IDEA
THAT HILLARY CLINTON AND THE
DNC PAID OVER, WHAT,
$12 MILLION TO FINANCE THIS
SALACIOUS UNVERIFIED DOSSIER
THAT USED EVEN RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT SOURCES?
NOW THAT WAS IN MAY OF 2017.
WE NOW KNOW FROM THE G.O.P.
MEMOS THAT APPROXIMATELY
SEVEN MONTHS EARLIER IN
OCTOBER, OF 2016, THAT THE
FBI, THE DOJ, THEY WERE
USING THAT DOSSIER AS THE
BULK OF THE FISA APPLICATION
TO GET THE WARRANT TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE
CARTER PAGE.
NOW, WE HAVE ALSO DISCOVERED
THAT THE FBI AND THE DOJ
LIED TO THE FISA COURT
JUDGE.
THEY NEVER SAID,NER TOLD THE
JUDGE ALTHOUGH THEY KNEW IT
THAT CLINTON PAID FOR THE
DOSSIER.
INSTEAD, THEY THOUGHT THEY
WERE CLEVER.
THEY PUT A FOOTNOTE IN THE
APPLICATION ABOUT THE
DOSSIER, PERHAPS, HAVING
SOME POLITICAL AFFILIATION.
SO BRENNAN WAS EITHER THE
MOST UNINFORMED CIA DIRECTOR
IN THE HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY OR WAS HE LYING TO
CONGRESS?
THAT'S JUST THE START OF
BRENNAN'S PROBLEMS.
PAUL OFFICER J IS ALSO
DISCOVERING HOW BRENNAN
ALLEGEDLY PUSHED INFORMATION
ABOUT THIS DOSSIER TO THE
FBI AND DEMOCRATIC LEADERS.
SOURCE TELLING SPERRY QUOTE
JOHN BRENNAN DID MORE THAN
ANYONE TO PROMULGATE THE
DIRTY DOSSIER.
HE WEAPONIZED FALSE
INTELLIGENCE AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP.
PAUL SPERRY GIVES SPURT
DETAILS ABOUT BRENNAN'S
EFFORTS TO DAMAGE THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WITH THE PHONY
DOSSIER.
ACCORDING TO NUMEROUS
REPORTS ON AUGUST THE 25TH,
2016, BRENNAN BRIEFED THE
FORMER SENATE MINORITY
LEADER HARRY REID ABOUT WHAT
HE SAID WAS RUSSIA TRYING TO
HELP TRUMP WIN THE ELECTION.
AND TWO DAYS LATER SENATOR
REID FIRES OFF A LETTER TO
JAMES COMEY DEMANDING THE
FBI INVESTIGATE THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLUDING WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
NOW, REID WROTE IN PART,
QUOTE:  THE EVIDENCE OF
DIRECT CONNECTION BETWEEN
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT AND
DONALD TRUMP'S PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN CONTINUES TO MOUNT.
AND THEN REID GOES ON TO
SPECIFICALLY MENTION AN
ALLEGATION FROM THE PHONY
DOSSIER ABOUT A TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE GOING TO
MOSCOW IN JULY OF 2016.
WE KNOW WHO THAT PERSON WAS.
THAT WAS CARTER PAGE.
WEIRD.
HOW WOULD THEN SENATOR REID
HAVE KNOWN THAT?
DID BRENNAN A COUPLE OF DAYS
EARLIER, DID HE BRIEF REID
ABOUT THE FAKE NEWS DOCUMENT
PUT TOGETHER BY CHRISTOPHER
STEELE THAT WAS PAID FOR BY
HILLARY CLINTON?
>> REID PUBLICLY ENCOURAGED
THE FBI TO INVESTIGATE THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
NOW, THAT'S CALLED, I THE
WAY I LOOK AT IT TRYING TO
INFLUENCE AN ELECTION.
THAT WASN'T REID'S ONLY
ATTEMPT TO DO.
SO FORMER SENATOR PUT OUT A
SECOND LETTER TO COMEY
BEFORE THE ELECTION OF
OCTOBER OF 2016 AND HE
WRITES THIS:  IN MY
COMMUNICATIONS WITH YOU AND
OTHER TOP OFFICIALS IN THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COMMUNITY,
IT HAS BECOME CLEAR THAT YOU
POSSESS EXPLOSIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT CLOSE TIES
AND COORDINATION BETWEEN
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS TOP
ADVISORS AND RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT U OKAY.
WHO WERE THE TOP OFFICIALS
HARRY REID IS TALKING ABOUT?
WAS IT BRENNAN?
WE KNOW FROM REPORTS THAT
REID WAS BRIEFED BY THE
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR.
THAT WAS BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
NOW, AS FOR AFTER THE
ELECTIONS, PAUL SPERRY IS
REPORTING THAT BRENNAN HAD
INFORMATION FROM THE STEELE
DOSSIER, INCLUDED IN THE
PRESIDENT'S DAILY
INTELLIGENCE BRIEFING.
NOW, THOSE DETAILS WERE THEN
LEAKED TO THE PRESS AND CNN,
"THE WASHINGTON POST," "NEW
YORK TIMES," THEY ALL
REPORTED ON HIM.
AND THEN MONTHS LATER WHEN
TESTIFYING BRENNAN THEN SAID
THAT DETAILS FROM THE
DOSSIER WEREN'T GOOD ENOUGH
TO INCLUDE IN THE JANUARY
JANUARY 2017 INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY REPORT ABOUT
RUSSIAN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
OKAY.
THEY USED IT IN OCTOBER TO
GET THE FISA WARRANT.
SO DESPITE ALL OF THESE
FACTS, ALL THIS INFORMATION,
BRENNAN STILL APPEARS TO BE
CLAIMING HE KNOWS NOTHING
ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
AND NOW HERE IS WHAT HE SAID
ON MEET THE PRESS EARLIER
THIS MONTH.
TAKE A CLOSE LISTEN.
>> WHEN DID YOU FIRST LEARN
OF THE SO-CALLED STEELE
DOSSIER AND WHAT CHRISTOPHER
STEELE WAS DOING?
>> WELL, IT WAS NOT A VERY
WELL KEPT SECRET AMONG PRESS
CIRCLES FOR SEVERAL MONTHS
BEFORE IT CAME OUT.
AND IT WAS IN LATE SUMMER OF
2016 WHEN THERE WAS SOME
INDIVIDUALS FROM THE VARIOUS
U.S. NEWS OUTLETS WHO ASKED
ME ABOUT MY FAMILIARITY WITH
IT.
AND I HAD HEARD JUST
SNIPPETS ABOUT IT.
I DID NOT KNOW WHAT WAS IN
THERE.
I DID NOT SEE IT UNTIL LATER
IN THAT YEAR.
I THINK IT WAS IN DECEMBER.
BUT I WAS UNAWARE OF THE
PROVIDENCE OF IT AS WELL AS
WHAT WAS IN IT.
IT DID NOT PLAY ANY ROLE
WHATSOEVER IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
ASSESSMENTS THAT WAS DONE
THAT WAS PRESENTED TO THEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND THEN
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, TONIGHT
BRENNAN CLEARLY HAS
EXPLAINING TO DO.
IF BRENNAN DIDN'T KNOW MUCH
ABOUT THE DOSSIER AND DIDN'T
SEE THE THING UNTIL A MONTH
AFTER THE ELECTION, THEN WHY
WAS HARRY REID SPECIFICALLY
REFERENCING IT IN AUGUST OF
2016 AFTER BEING BRIEFED BY
BRENNAN?
AND WHY, ACCORDING TO SPERRY
DID BRENNAN INSIST THAT
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
DOSSIER BE INCLUDED IN
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S DAILY
INTELLIGENCE BRIEFING?
NOW, THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF
THE MAJOR BURNING QUESTIONS
THAT JOHN BRENNAN HAS TO
ANSWER TONIGHT.
PAUL OFFICER J IS ALSO
REPORTING THAT THE FORMER
OBAMA DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE, JAMES CLAPPER,
HE IS NOW FACING SCRUTINY.
SERIOUS QUESTIONS ARE BEING
RAISED ABOUT WHAT CLAPPER
TOLD FAKE NEWS, CNN, ABOUT
THE DOSSIER BACK IN
OCTOBER 2017.
LET'S WATCH HIM.
>> WITH RESPECT TO THE
DOSSIER ITSELF, THE KEY
THING IS IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHO PAID FOR IT.
IT'S WHAT THE DOSSIER SAID
AND THE EXTENT TO WHICH IT
IS CORROBORATED OR NOT.
WE HAD SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
IT FROM A STANDPOINT OF ITS
SOURCING, WHICH WE COULDN'T
CORROBORATE.
>> UM-HUH.
>> AT THE SAME TIME, SOME OF
THE SUBSTANTIVE CONTENT, NOT
ALL OF IT, BUT SOME OF THE
SUBSTANTIVE CONTENT OF THE
DOSSIER WE WERE ABLE TO
CORROBORATE IN OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
ASSESSMENT WHICH FROM OTHER
SOURCES AND WHICH WE HAD
VERY HIGH CONFIDENCE LEVEL.
>> Sean: THAT'S FASCINATING
BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE GOING
BACK TO OCTOBER IS CLAPPER.
HE IS TRYING TO LAY THE
GROUNDWORK FOR THE ARGUMENT
THAT OH, IT DOESN'T REALLY
MATTER THAT HILLARY CLINTON
PAID FOR THE RUSSIAN DOSSIER
WITH RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
LIES.
ALL IN AN EFFORT TO LIE TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
INFLUENCE AN ELECTION.
AND IS IT APPEARS CLAPPER IS
ALSO TRYING TO COVER HIS
TRACKS BECAUSE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION KNEW WELL
BEFORE THEN THAT CLINTON
SHELLED OUT 12 MILLION
DOSSIER DOLLARS FOR
CHRISTOPHER STEELE TO WRITE
THIS RUSSIA PROPAGANDA.
OTHER FASCINATING ASPECT
THAT SPERRY POINTS OUT ABOUT
CLAPPER WANT COMMENTS,
CLAPPER CLAIMS THAT SOME
PARTS OF THE DOSSIER WERE
CORROBORATED.
ALL RIGHT, THE QUESTION IS,
WHICH ONES?
AND HOW?
NOW, REMEMBER, THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE MEMO
EXPOSES HOW IN THEIR
APPLICATION FOR THAT FISA
WARRANT THAT THE FBI SAYS IT
VERIFIED THE DOSSIER WITH
THE YAHOO NEWS ARTICLE THAT
WAS WRITTEN BY MICHAEL
ISIKOFF AND MICHAEL
ISIKOFF'S SOURCE WAS
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
SO THE FBI NEVER ACTUALLY
INDEPENDENTLY VERIFIED ANY
OF THIS.
SO IS THAT WHAT CLAPPER IS
TALKING ABOUT?
SO IT'S TIME NOW FOR BOTH
BRENEMAN AND CLAP TORE FACE
CONGRESS.
THEY NEED TO GO BACK UNDER
OATH AND TALK ABOUT WHAT
THEY KNEW, WHAT THEY FOUND
AND WHEN THEY FOUND IT.
WE DID REACH OUT TO HARRY
REID, JOHN BRENNAN AND JAMES
CLAPPER FOR COMMENTS.
THEY DIDN'T GET BACK TO US.
I'M NOT GOING TO HOLD MY
BREATH.
PRESSURE IS MOUNTING ON
FORMER OBAMA NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR SUSAN RICE
TO START ANSWERING
QUESTIONS.
WHY DID SHE EMAIL HERSELF ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
INAUGURATION DAY ABOUT AN
IMPORTANT MEETING THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD WITH
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR COMEY
WAY BACK 15 DAYS EARLIER ON
JANUARY 5TH?
NOW SENATORS GRASSLEY AND
GRAHAM ARE OUT WITH A LETTER
DEMANDING THAT RICE EXPLAIN
HERSELF.
ACCORDING TO THE SENATORS,
THEY DISCUSSED THE
JANUARY 5TH EMAIL AS PART OF
A NATIONAL ARCHIVES REQUEST
ABOUT MEETINGS BETWEEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND FORMER
FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY
REGARDING THE BUREAU'S
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
SO WHEN THE EMAIL TO
HERSELF, LET ME SEND A AN
EMAIL TO SELF WHICH SENATOR
GRAHAM IS CALLING
DISTURBING.
RICE WRITES PRESIDENT OBAMA
BEGAN THE CONVERSATION BY
STRESSING HIS CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING THAT
EVERY ASPECT OF THIS ISSUE
IS HANDLED BY THE
INTELLIGENCE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITIES BY
THE BOOK.
THE PRESIDENT STRESSED THAT
HE IS NOT ASKING ABOUT
INITIATING OR INSTRUCTING
ANYTHING FROM A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE.
HE REITERATED THAT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TEAM NEEDS TO
PROCEED AS IT NORMALLY WAS
BY THE BOOK.
FROM A NATIONAL SECURITY
PERSPECTIVE PRESIDENT OBAMA
SAID HE WANTS TO BE SURE AS
WE ENGAGE WITH THE INCOMING
TEAM THAT WE ARE MINDFUL TO
ASCERTAIN IF THERE IS ANY
REASON THAT WE CANNOT SHARE
INFORMATION FULLY AS IT
RELATES TO RUSSIA.
WHAT'S HIS ROLE IN THIS?
NOW THE NEXT PART OF THAT IS
REDACTED AND BEFORE WE
CONTINUE, WHY WOULD THE
PRESIDENT NOT WANT TO SHARE
INFORMATION WITH THE TRUMP
TRANSITION TEAM?
WHAT DOES HE THINK MIGHT
HAVE HAPPENED?
WHO TOLD HIM WHAT, WHEN, AND
WHERE?
REMEMBER, OBAMA DID AMEND
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER 12333
THAT ALLOWED THE WIDESPREAD
SHARING OF WIDESPREAD RAW
INFORMATION ACROSS 16
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES BUT HE
DIDN'T LIVE WITH THAT RULE
UNDER HIS ADMINISTRATION.
RICE THEN CONTINUES, QUOTE:
THE PRESIDENT ASKED COMEY TO
INFORM HIM IF ANYTHING
CHANGES IN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS THAT SHOULD EFFECT HOW
WE SHARE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION WITH THE
INCOMING TEAM.
COMEY SAID HE WOULD.
NOW IN A STATEMENT TO
FOXNEWS.COM SUSAN RICE'S
ATTORNEY IS CLAIMING TONIGHT
THAT WHAT SHE DID WAS NOT
UNUSUAL.
WAS MERELY AN ATTEMPT FOR
RICE TO MEMORIALIZED THE
MEETING FOR THE RECORD.
15 DAYS LATER?
ATTACK GRASSLEY AND GRAHAM
FOR DARING TO ASK THE
QUESTION.
IT'S ALL VERY, VERY STRANGE.
THERE IS MORE TO THIS STORY,
THAT, I CAN PROMISE YOU.
EVENTUALLY WE WILL UNPEAL
THAT ONION.
IT WILL BE INVESTIGATED.
ALSO TONIGHT GREAT REPORTING
ROWAN SCARBOROUGH FROM "THE
WASHINGTON TIMES."
HE IS HIGHLIGHTING ALL OF
THE ALLEGATIONS IN THIS
PHONY DOSSIER JET TO BE
VERIFIED.
SCARBOROUGH WRITING SUSPECTS
BEEN 20 MONTHS SINCE FORMER
BRITISH SPY CHRISTOPHER
STEELE WENT TO THE FBI HE
POINTS OUT 10 PAGES FROM THE
DOSSIER NEVER BEEN VERIFIED.
WE WILL GIVE YOU TOP FIVE
FOR CONSTRAINTS OF TIME.
TRUMP CAMPAIGN LAUNCHED
EXTENSIVE CONSPIRACY WITH
THE KREMLIN TO INTERFERE IN
THE 2016 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
SCARBOROUGH NOTES RIGHTLY SO
IT HASN'T BEEN VERIFIED.
MR. TRUMP FOR DECADES, A
DEVELOPER OF TALL BUILDINGS,
MAINTAINED AN 8-YEAR
RELATIONSHIP OF GIVE AND
TAKE WITH RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE.
NOT VERIFIED.
MR. TRUMP AND SENIOR
CAMPAIGN AIDS ACTIVELY
SUPPORTED THE RUSSIAN
HACKING OF DEMOCRATIC PARTY
COMPUTERS TO STEEL AND
RELEASE STOLEN EMAILS.
OKAY.
NEVER VIFD.
PAGE CONSPIRED WITH MOSCOW
TO HACK THE DEMOCRATS'
COMPUTERS.
THAT WASN'T VERIFIED EITHER.
BY THE WAY THE HACKING
STARTED IN 2015 AND NEITHER
PAGE NOR MANAFORT WERE PART
OF THE CAMPAIGN THEN AND
BOTH DENY THE CHARGES IN
THAT CASE.
AND THE LAST THE DOSSIER
SAYS PAGE MEANT WITH TWO TOP
KREMLIN OPERATIVES AND
DISCUSSED BRIBES FOR WORKING
TO LIFT ECONOMIC SANCTIONS.
SCARBOROUGH WRITES THAT
CARTER PAGE TESTIFY UNDER
OATH THAT HE NEVER MET OR
TALKED TO THOSE PEOPLE.
PAGE ALSO FILED LIBEL
LAWSUITS.
THAT'S JUST SOIL OF THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT HAVE NEVER
BEEN VERIFIED.
IN THIS PHONY DOSSIER.
ALTHOUGH I UNDERSTAND PEOPLE
ARE BEING PAID TO TRY TO
VERIFY IT TO THIS DAY.
NOW YET AS THE G.O.P. MEMOS
HAVE EXPOSED, THE BULK OF
THAT FISA APPLICATION
CONSISTED OF THIS UNVERIFIED
DOSSIER AND JAMES COMEY AND
THE FBI NEVER BOTHERED TO
VERIFY IT.
NEITHER DID FUSION G.P.S.
NOBODY VERIFIED IT.
WE CAN'T VERIFY ANY OF IT TO
THIS DAY.
ALTHOUGH A LOT HAS BEEN
PROVEN FALSE.
NOW, ALSO BREAKING THIS HOUR
BYRON YORK HAS A STUNNING
REPORT.
HERE'S HIS HEADLINE.
COMEY TOLD CONGRESS THE FBI
AGENTS DIDN'T THINK MICHAEL
FLYNN LIED.
AND ACCORDING TO BYRON YORK
DURING A MARCH 2017 BRIEFING
TO MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
COMEY SAID THE FBI AGENTS
WHO INTERVIEW LIEUTENANT
GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN DID
NOT THINK THAT HE LIED OR
THAT ANY INACCURACIES IN HIS
STATEMENTS WERE INTENTIONAL.
COMEY ADDED THE AGENTS
DIDN'T THINK FLYNN WOULD BE
CHARGED WITH A KR50EU78
RELATING TO THE
CRLATING TO THE
CRIMTING TO THE
CRIMEING TO THE
CRIME RG TO THE
CRIME RELTO THE
CRIME RELAT THE
CRIME RELATINHE
CRIME RELATINGE
CRIME RELATINGTO THE FBI.
WHY WAS HE CHARGED WITH A
CRIME LYING TO THE FBI.
PETER STRZOK IN FACT
INTERVIEWED GENERAL FLYNN.